I have the great privilege to introduce
to you Travis today
um Travis other third and led the
creation of Industry Cornerstone such as
numpy sci-fi Namba and Konda and of
course also the paidea conference Series
so thank you for making this possible
um Travis also founded Anaconda so after
I knew all of that I was like I don't
know if Travis has ever slept but
um with coincide Travis has also
assembled some of the top talent in the
industry and I'm sure he's going to talk
about that today
and some fun fact about Travis because I
was going around some friends like do
you know Travis like do you have
anything I can share that's you know fun
about him and he's like apparently
Travis is well known for being a great
singer so I don't know if he's gonna
demonstrate those skill sets today but
it's up to him if he wants to wrap up
with that
and they're also late but not least
Travis is also someone who is well known
for staying up late at night during
akaton for example at the Academy
Illinois that's a fun fact from Carol
willing we'll act around with you on
Jupiter and Empire at 3am with students
and she said she had a blast doing it
and always having fun hacking with you
on projects so please everyone welcome
Travis thank you very much
[Applause]
oh
thank you Pierre thank you and thank you
to the conference organizers and the
invitation to come and speak this is a
phenomenal event thank you for getting
up and uh attending the uh the top the
early talk I know sometimes we probably
had a late night parties last night I
was hearing rumors about people at
different events uh so appreciate being
here I've been coming to a to community
events for a long time I really find
energy and I love coming here I I wanted
to give a little a tiny bit of
retrospective about kind of where we
came from and then why we're doing it
and maybe what's what kind of some of
the things I'm doing now hopefully uh
you'll see a little bit about what
you're going to do and what what the
work you're doing in kind of what I'm
doing if there's anything that's been
driving me for 30 25 28 years now as
I've been working on this community and
working on the software that drives us
it's uh really the potential the
potential to really uh build something
that matters build something that lasts
build something that brings us together
and kind of crosses the borders the the
separation between us and just and
brings us together
there's tremendous opportunities
tremendous power still I mean it may
seem like everything's been done may
seem like lots has happened
it's amazing how much opportunity there
still is like regardless
um so if anything you seize people out
there doing great work you see man I
wish I could do that I wish there was
something I would be doing that's
related to that just know that it's
there and if you want to talk to
somebody about it happy to talk to you
about possibilities after you talk to me
about ways to get started ways to kind
of find your own Vision find your own
story so the first pie did a workshop
was in 2012. this was basically at the
peak hadoopla essentially and everyone
was excited about scalable data and
python was just not talked about much
and you know Peter and Wes and Fernando
and others we Stefan got together and
we're saying hey we've got to do
something we've got to promote python
for data as well so we inaugurated this
Pai data Workshop several people helped
us bring it together Google allowed us
to do on the Googleplex we went with
Guido there we've been doing this for 11
years and then of course it's blossomed
and grown it was amazing just how much
interest there was in this kind of
gathering this kind of enthusiasm and it
just took off thousands of people have
contributed I'm just visiting with the
volunteers this morning who a show who
showed up to kind of help organize Pai
data here it's amazing it seems like
everywhere every part of the world you
do that there's there's people that want
to help people that will do it that's
been happening for 11 years
the movement actually started 10 years
before that so you know Pi did it in
2012 it had already been 10 years the
Sci-Fi conference I think I heard you
learned some of this history before but
I went back to try when was that
actually happening it was September 5th
of 2002. I remember that gathering in
Pasadena there are only 70 folks and
there's this nice ride up by by somebody
I mean
um actually commenting talking
discussing you know if you if you're
looking for something to do write a blog
about what you experienced this today
here today you know do that talk about
what you're seeing give your perspective
there's a lot of opportunity to
contribute and to help people make sense
of this uh phenomenal Movement we call
Open Source Community activity that just
is is the sum of all of us and it's
amazing what can happen if we are kind
of doing it with good intentions doing a
good doing it with a heart of service
with a desire to help each other or
desire to give when that happens it's
amazing what's produced and everything
that you see
in the python ecosystem is really coming
from that from that Spirit from that
space so this happened in 2002
um
but it actually started even earlier in
that it started really I think uh when
Guido wrote python he started in 1989
first released in 91 the first version
came out in 94. I started using python
in 98. uh show of hands anybody started
using python before 1998 I know there's
probably somebody here
no no I'm the oldest one okay that's
fine I I was python 1.4.2
um but 95 this is the thread this is the
Matrix Sig thread that was active when I
showed up on the scene right so what got
me excited was there was already people
Gathering now the watering hole back
then was a mailing list and you go to
the archives here and see it
mail.python.org still holds these
archives you can go back and read
through these messages that people just
posted to an email that was the way we
communicated there was no Facebook there
was no Instagram there was no Snapchat
no Tick Tock we communicated by writing
messages on email and hoping we weren't
offending somebody which we didn't
always do we often offended people uh
you know we got used to how do we write
and we didn't use emojis very often so
often things are misinterpreted but
there was a lot of you could see even
then there was this passion there's this
desire to build something and uh you
know Jim hugoten was there the very
first one Jim Fulton
um Matrix Sig 1995.
so this scipy data community and forgive
me for kind of inventing a concept here
but sci-fi data Community has been going
for 28 years
uh
and this is just one event from 2009
actually the Gael had posted I think he
circled himself in that picture
so we've had almost 30 years of
innovation coming together building
creating something something for experts
something for science something for
people that want to use software to
better the world
um we're not there yet right actually I
don't think we're even that close I'm
excited by what's coming out and what's
possible I think there's enormous
innovations that have been occurring
that will enable us to accelerate this
God this this organization here's just a
couple of things that I still think
about that we need that we that we
needed then we still need now there's
work to do to accomplish these things
thriving open source communities and
thriving means they're welcome there's
lots of people in them people aren't
they're still you know it's hard to get
into them sometimes there's a lot of
people who are eager to kind of learn
but they don't know exactly where to
start so how do you enable these
sustainable thriving now how to help
them sustain there's a lot of work there
to still do I have this concept I call
Open Source aligned businesses in some
sense that's what I've been really doing
for the past 15 years is trying to
figure out how to create and work with
and partner with and organize open
source aligned businesses and I think
the possibilities are enormous there
actually if we open and just just think
about the possibilities for alignment
and possibilities and we recognize the
critical nature of cooperation at scale
and the critical nature that business
actually plays in cooperation at scale
and don't see it as a as a bad thing see
is a good thing but just there are bad
ways to do it just like there are bad
ways to interact in the community other
better ways to do business but they're
great ways to do business and they're
great ways to interact with the
community as well
then more specifically you know software
that allows experts in other fields
which many of us are most people in the
pi to the community
you're here because you're an expert in
some other field you've studied science
you've studied engineering you've
studied data use
um you studied medicine I don't know if
you have any uh we probably have some
medical professionals but not
necessarily you know Physicians here how
do you help
us who have these other desires other
interests use and direct computational
resources without sacrificing
performance how to do it easily we still
struggle with that like we still you
know these new Innovations occur awesome
we can take advantage of gpus but coding
them is terrible you know how to we can
take advantage of these wonderful
clusters of machines but coding them is
challenging some of these problems are
real and they're still here absolutely
still here and they've been here for a
long time so there's plenty of
opportunity to make it better if we keep
focused on what are we trying to
accomplish what do we try to help
another thing that ever since I became
aware of this problem I'm not
particularly a visualization expert
myself but I've been around others who
are and I've seen oh this is absolutely
what I want I want other people want it
too people want live dashboards and
visualizations
we can create them in lots of ways today
but they're kind of you know contained
how do you make a visualization so it's
always active it's always live it's
always able to just receive the data
there's lots of problems there I mean
you go dig deep into that problem
realize okay there's more than just a
technology here there's also who get I
mean how do you update the data what
happens when it changes how is the data
collected there's all kinds of questions
there how do you actually accomplish
this but I know that every a lot of
people want this like every business I
go into this is essentially they love it
if you give them a dashboard or you give
them a visualization or a way to go from
here's what I'm trying to accomplish
here's my data here's the result that we
can make decisions around and then of
course the ability to share and
reproduce these systems we produce these
systems easily fluidly that's still a
challenge today despite many years you
know several decades of work by many
people trying to make it better and
there are better Solutions than there
were 20 years ago it's still not done
there's still lots of opportunity to
improve this question of how do we
reproduce software that helps people
accomplish their goal besides computers
you know we love computers I love
computers but you know frankly life is
more than computers right hopefully all
of you have interests outside of us all
you have interests that you're trying to
accomplish and how do we use computers
to help us accomplish those things
lots of possibilities
I like to show this side almost just to
orient me you know actually I mean you
know just oh my gosh what's what we've
been doing a lot of things for a long
time
um with a lot of people uh all the way
since 91 to till today and uh you know
people have seen this a lot of things
I've done in the past I want to talk
today a little bit about things I'll
talk a little bit about what kind of how
I oriented but mostly about what I'm
doing today and then a little bit about
where I think we can go and how do we go
better so I like to show this slide
because I've emphasized a very important
concept which is it matters that you
share what you're doing
and you know I'm sure Michael Miller
does I've actually never met him again
Michael Miller wrote table i o released
to the web just was out there when I
searched for it I was a young graduate
student I wanted to read a dicom format
which is a medical imaging format so I
could read MRI images I was trying to do
processing with them how do I do this I
just found numeric and Python and I
liked it I'd spent a year doing it
actually started in 97 but a year later
I realized I could still read the code I
said I got to get into this more that
was a different experience that I've had
with pearl I could read what I wrote and
I said I should play with this a little
more actually so then I got into it I
said well I need to read data so how do
I do that well I can write some C code
back in the day extending python was
writing the C code basically and that's
what we've been doing the Sci-Fi data
Community for years is not you know
writing python code and wishing it were
faster we've been writing extension
modules now in scython and number you
can do the same thing we're writing C
code to make it fast and then using
python as glue as as scripting over our
outer layer glue a lot of conversations
around python completely missed the
point
they sort of by them slow you can't do
this you can't do that like that's not
what we've been doing you know look
deeper look at what's happening actually
we've been using the expressivity of
python to steer our large codes which
are still backed by low-level libraries
now recently past 10 years or so we've
been able to even write fast code with
higher level syntax I think there's a
lot of ways to go still there but
because Michael Miller put his stuff I
did what I I don't mind if you do cut
and paste programming sometimes we laugh
but that's what we're all doing now with
chat CBT we're doing it in Spades right
which is cut and Pace what it produces
now I I will caveat it's not unthinking
cut Pace programming Right In fact when
you have a piece of code that you're
cutting in and using to help develop
your your story The thinking just begins
right you now you have to debug you have
to adapt you have to review it's not
just fire and forget it's oh thank you
for the help getting me started getting
me out of my fuzz of I don't know what
to do let me start someplace now I have
to iterate and have to work hard but I
appreciated that it gave me something to
start with and I you know took
everything and everything that's wrong
with it was my fault numpyio released
98. and I just put it out there on the
net said you know hoped it was a tarball
it wasn't easy to install
easy install came much later it was a
source code you had to download it
install it compile it and so you know
that its distribution was limited to
about four people
uh it wasn't until you get binary
installations people realize okay this
really matters
um but then also Guido had written a
really good essay on how to reference
how do you handle reference counting
because a lot of people complain about
writing extension modules because you
have to count references it's actually
pretty pretty significant if you if you
don't you leak memory it's kind of an
approach to doing that a way to think
about it I read that essay kind of
grocked it got got the idea and then
um you know got better at over time I
made a lot of mistakes but you know just
documentation communicating about what
you've done which is always an
opportunity I guarantee every single
open source product out there no matter
how mature the maintainers would
appreciate improved and better
documentation on some segment
documentation and testing so this led
directly to sci-fi like sci-fi exists
because this and you know other people
who contribute to site by doing
something similar now scipy very
ambitious so definitely one of my
weaknesses I suppose is I'm always
looking big and you know kind of you
know um
probably taking on more than I can
handle right always punching above what
I what what I probably should be doing
but I can't help it I just you know when
you see something you want something to
exist so badly you just push at it and
you try to do everything you can to make
it exist sci-fi was the was the first
example so sci-fi started as you know we
wanted to be everything we wanted to be
open source all the things all the all
the things you might want to do as a
scientist and one
easy to install package now what we
didn't realize is essentially because
the install problems of python you had
to install one exe basically scipy was
actually our very first distribution of
python this Mass gradient as a library
was released a distribution of a bunch
of libraries and what became challenging
is managing scipy
um with like four people right and and
not only just the fact that all of us
couldn't we had to collect like
thousands more people like we need to
organize thousands thousands of more
people and there's real problems with
that there's problems not only of
communication scale like how do you
actually have a team meeting when you've
got thousands of contributors like you
all tried Zoom we've all gotten really
good at Zoom these past few years right
but on a zoom meeting
how many people before you stop being
able to really have a collaborative
conversation it's just more speaking out
people like you can speak at lots of
people assume but how do you speak with
people it's hard so sci-fi we had that
problem early on in about 2004 or five
we kind of recognized this and some
smart people decided hey we should do
some psych kits the psych kit phenomenon
emergency kit learn which is the single
most popular sidekit likely emerge from
that kind of realization we can't put
all the things in scipy even though it's
a nice distribution but that's
essentially why you know a scientist
trained in medical physics ended up
founding a company that became known for
Distributing python binaries right
basically like how did that happen right
it's it's this it's sci-fi it's because
you know just trying to help people just
trying to get stuff installed
now a lot of people know me for numpy
not realizing that scipy came first
sci-fi came first and numpy was actually
written to save scipy it was written to
kind of help the community keep together
it was a fledgling Community I didn't I
really really was pained to see that
libraries are being written for another
array object you had to copy the data
from one array to another there wasn't
an easy way to exchange data at the time
so numpy was written also I became a
python core developer and improved the
buffer protocol so the memory view
object and the buffer protocol in Python
was I contributed that at the same time
memory product itself was improved by
Antoine and Stefan later so um because I
it was barely functional after I left it
but the buffer protocol I wanted to make
sure the structure so you know there's
an old adage of fix it twice when you
see a problem
you fix the proximal problem with the
immediate problem but then the ultimate
problem could you fix that too so to
avoid the problem in the future so I
felt like we we at least did that here
wrote numpy to merge the libraries
together but also wrote a buffer
protocol so that even when new array
libraries may arise in the future they
would at least be able to share data so
you wouldn't have to copy data back and
forth
so that's kind of how I got started uh
and and many of you heard know the story
of anaconda and Peter may say more today
but today I'm going to talk more about
what I'm doing today and kind of the
efforts we're involved with today
essentially I'm looking to help people
still I'm just scratching my own itch
and my own desire to see the world a
better place to see these Technologies
improve and no I can't do it myself
right so I can't do it myself I can't
just sit and code all day and have
something that I'm I'm happy with so
what do I do and so I spend a lot of
time finding people finding money
finding business ideas cooperating with
folks
um you know Tech Visionaries Founders
investors Partners people to work with
to try to who are aligned with me kind
of Open Source aligned people to create
this Community Driven open source world
that I'd like to see and these are some
of the efforts here that are happening
um
so many people know the story about
anaconda and if you don't come talk to
me I'm happy to talk to you about it in
some depth but I thought I'd start with
where you know leaving Anaconda I left
Anaconda because of some investor
difficulties essentially and if you want
to understand the details
um happy to talk about it not here
fortunately Anaconda is in is fantastic
hands now those those difficulties are
done and Anaconda is doing very very
well led by Peter with the same vision
the same energy and even better uh in
the same and better vision and doing
wonderful things they've got great
leaders over there so I can't speak
highly enough about Anaconda today
but at the time was struggling uh under
different investors and so I laughed
because I couldn't I have a bigger a
bigger purpose in mind I started
Anaconda to try to create a company that
would create products that would drive
Revenue to open source so I'm very
grateful for the Anaconda dividend
program essentially that's a very
valuable tool I'm very grateful that
Anaconda sponsored numb Focus that we
were able to incubate it and live and
hire early people in Num Focus to get it
started very grateful that numb Focus
has been continuing to Blossom under
Community leadership but I left with a
couple of folks Matt Harvard Ashley ball
to start Quan site
so quonsite is you know and this is
started as a it's Consulting in Labs one
of the really critical things and one of
the things I'm really proud of is we do
have a quantite Labs long long ago as
numpy and sci-fi were created after
uh six years eight years of anaconda
we're we're going okay the purpose of a
reason I left Academia to go into
business was to be able to support numpy
and sci-fi like that's why I did it
because I thought we need
entrepreneurship we need aligned
businesses maybe I should go try to help
because there wasn't funding for numpy
and sci-fi but I wanted these to get
funded how do we do that so you know
when quantite started where Anaconda was
doing wonderful things but still not
paying people to work on numpy and
sci-fi directly so one of the real
purposes of of quantite was to create a
Labs that would pay people and hire
people to work on open source uh uh at
least half their time uh half time to
full time so these are and we do that
partly by having a Consulting mission
that drives Revenue that drives we help
people use the tools more effectively
and solve business problems which there
are many lots of wasted money in
companies and some you know what I'm
talking about still today lots of people
spending lots of money
usually hiring teams of developers
inefficiently and effectively but not
using open source enough and we can I'm
happy to talk about ways to improve
those situations in your organization we
do that Consulting and part of that
funds this Labs then this other thought
occurred
and the reason I started a venture fund
was because I saw a way to actually have
all open have all companies contribute
to the benefit of all open source that
idea is still percolating but the
kwanzai initiate is actually doing
pretty well we've got we've invested in
14 companies so these are all together
we have our values here this kind of
taken from some slides from the deck uh
I won't bore you there
um this is kind of how we're organized
effectively we have the Consulting
division we have the labs division then
we have people managers effectively
um there is a concept called open teams
now open teams you'll hear a little bit
about I'll go into some conversation
because it is what I'm spending at least
half my time on today is something
called open teams and open teams is
essentially a support organization to
help support
people like quantite Labs people like
quantite others out there who want to do
something similar we feel like we can
scale the success of Kwanza and Quonset
labs to thousands more people and so we
want to help them we want to help you do
that so uh we basically have divided
into these three camps I'll talk more
about that if you haven't yet Go
download the quantite labs annual report
so proud of these folks this is Ralph
I'll go back here to the top Ralph
gomers uh Tanya Allard our co-directors
of the labs and everything good that's
happening at quantite Labs is
attributable to these folks so you know
the only thing I can take credit for is
trying to find the money and then
convincing Ralph to come start it and
try to and then and trying to run
interference then pulling Matt in to
help me
um who's some who's often a better
empath and a better facilitator of
difficult conversations so that's what
I'm going to be credit for but they've
done amazing work and I'm inspired every
day by the work they do so if you
haven't yet go read this lab report it's
uh pavirtha
wrote about this on the blog go to
quantite.org labs.quancing.org blog read
the annual report you can get a picture
and imagine a world where there's
hundreds of these and what we did with
our Venture fund is we've actually
committed 15 of any carried interest if
you know what that is it's fine but
every single Venture fund out there is
making a ton of money on open source not
all of them are making a ton of money
but several do make a lot of money they
should all be sponsoring open source
research Labs there is no reason not to
they should all be funding open source
research Labs it's an obvious obvious
pattern it's not hard to do and so if
anything I love that pattern to be to be
shared spread in fact some people said
hey you should be a venture you should
be just a venture investor I said that's
fantastic find me a venture fund that
will do this that will give its carried
interest to an open source research lab
and you'll have my ear right I mean
you're I'm eager to join
um we founded Pharaoh says it's
currently
um incubating it's it's there I love
this idea frankly if I could do nothing
else if someone said here's here's uh
you don't have to work anymore here's
retirement and you can just focus on one
thing I would focus on this uh we found
a way I think we found a way that would
sustain all of Open Source we just have
to convince every company to give a
portion of its uh revenue or a portion
of its Equity to the open source
communities they depend on and we
figured a way to do it actually with a
specific instrument that in a specific
organization kind of derivative
instrument after years of working in the
finance industry working in open source
working in you know business I I believe
we figure out a way to do this and we've
sampled it a few people have committed
to do it this will totally work but
it'll take you know five to ten years
and so I've got to find a pocket of
money that can sustain at least half a
million dollars a year for five to ten
years in order to really push on this so
if any of you have any uh you know if
you're looking you have a two and a half
million or five million dollars you're
looking just to put something that's
incredibly important that could
transform and create a trillion dollar
um uh exchange essentially there's an
incredible idea here and I'd love to
talk to you about it we're looking for
leaders and investors to make this
really happen
so you know I'm patient right it took uh
17 years for sci-fi to reach 1.0 I was I
left Academia because I didn't publish
enough my papers were unknown I wrote
some papers but my department was
unclear if they'd be impactful right it
took you know a while it took more than
the two years they were going to give me
to evaluate the success of numpy but in
again not because of my efforts
specifically because of others who took
on this Banner to help make help make
open source palatable in Academia this
paper was published in nature methods
which now has more citations than every
paper I've ever published uh on on numpy
or sci-fi so it's really helped from a
perspective of oh Google Scholar says
yeah you're an academic now because you
have this reference
um but it takes patience takes
persistence you know and uh there's
still a long ways to go it takes
collaboration so I am patient right so
that's partly part of the secret is to
just
know and have have conviction is what
you're accomplishing not blind
conviction like I'm constantly updating
and thinking how do I do this better but
my conviction is in People my conviction
is in you my conviction is in the power
of cooperation and the power of serving
others to make something better so and
that's worth that's worth driving
um
uh uh it's worth working for it's worth
continuing to to work and to deal and to
struggle and to not have things go
perfectly every day uh so we're excited
I'm excited about that
so I'm going to talk a little about open
teams many people don't know much about
open teams partly because we've been
quietly trying to incubate it trying to
understand what it is trying to
understand how we're going to help
everybody it's a really ambitious idea
and it actually has three three
divisions three segments these are all
separate companies actually uh with
leaders that are helping them grow so
first quantite Futures is the parent
that kind of helps funding it's
basically a private Equity small private
Equity I say that tongue-in-cheek like I
have a bunch of money I have some and I
keep funneling every uh Penny I can find
into supporting these efforts
um first of all there's an incubator so
incubator will go into detail about that
actually Raven's here she's helped
organize Pi data she uh is the opp
operations of incubator so go say hi to
her when if you get a chance uh that
kind of is a help spin outs it manages
the fund it's a venture Services firm
it's what it's what I'll be doing for
the rest of my life is helping there
right an incubator has other spin outs
essentially and I'm kind of being
borrowed as a CEO at open teams right
now until I can find other people to
help lead it but open teams focuses on
the what we call an Osa Network open
source architect open source advisor
open source Enthusiast these are this
architect Community is what we're
driving in open teams people with tech
leadership skills people with
experienced project leaders they might
be maintainers might be users might be
people but people with significant
experience that care about building
Better Business Solutions for open
source for
using open source
thousands and thousands of businesses
are using open source today hundreds of
thousands of business open source today
they need tech leadership that
understands how to do it well how to mix
the right mix of product how to mix to
write about how do you integrate with
the open source Community how do you
contribute back to the open source
community so our goal at open teams to
build this community of advisors and
people who are ready maybe they're maybe
they'll be paid to do it maybe they
won't maybe they'll work at their
company they may be looking for a job
maybe not probably a fraction maybe only
five percent are looking for for work as
an advisor and the others are looking to
just share ideas and share experience so
that's what we're doing and then then we
also have a project success story
um so a few team members Matt braddon
John Raven I mentioned and NASA's joined
us recently from the Community
Management world uh Brian Kate these are
there's a lot more but fortunately I
think we're up to about
75 people that support us here uh again
with the uh on top of the 70 to 80
developers that we work with at kwanzai
and quantite labs and our other
companies
so again
um
I need to look at the clock to make sure
I don't go over I want to I want to end
with a few other slides so I've got
probably 10 more minutes
if you're interested in talking about
any of these things partly the reason to
show you is to come talk to me I'm happy
to explain incubator has an entrepreneur
residence program we're looking for
people that want to create companies and
start companies uh actually even before
you know if you want to start a company
you know you may want to and there's we
call it entrepreneur residence program
we help you get that company started
with the right uh kind of Ip basically
it's the problem I have when I was
starting I was a a I had a family I
thought to start a company I couldn't
just eat ramen I had to have a job I
couldn't go without money for a year or
two years hoping to get a startup off
the ground so I had to work someplace
but usually when I work someplace and
the people who you work for don't want
you to start a company because they want
to own everything that you do so how do
you actually you know it's a little
easier now in some organizations but how
do you square that how do you make that
work incubator is is intended to solve
that problem and then when those
companies start it provides fractional
Services the legal department marketing
department starting a company is hard
it's hard because you have have to
integrate more than you are like that's
the hardest thing about it is it's much
much more than any skill you have and
you're super skilled and you have to be
super skilled in something but you need
more you need to build teams of really
skilled people that are even better than
you across things you don't even know
about and so how do you do that well you
just kind of keep finding people to help
you finding Partners an incubator can
help
so then we have a venture capital fund
Quonset initiate that funds and invests
in that we're on fund two now we're
looking to raise fund three next year
and it invests in companies either that
are looking for technology open source
or are looking open source technologists
looking for Marketing sales Business
Development help those two things we end
up supporting
um
incubator is now spun out of venture
Studio company which means a company
that is being managed and run
essentially from the incubator called
local teams Global Noble teams global
has something called open source
Professional Network this is the
original idea of open teams rebranded
re-engaged and it's basically to create
a talent Network a LinkedIn for open
source creators a community that's
supporting open source careers everybody
in the world ought to be able to have an
open source career not to be able to
have people help them with an open
source career how do I sign contracts
that have the right legal terms so I can
have my contributions get back to the
community how can I make sure that
finally find a good job where the
company supports open source and they're
not just going to exploit my open source
contributions but they're they're
they're collaborative they're open
source aligned open source Professional
Network aims to help do that open teams
Global is an HR company basically I say
I say this all the time open source is a
global phenomena people from all over
the world work together but employment
is very local
jurisdictions I mean when you're
employed somewhere you're interacting
with the local tax codes the local uh
organization folks how do you do that
it's actually somewhat challenging and
so openings Global is a potentially a
Global Employment organization currently
we are only employing in certain
countries in other countries we help we
we provide advice and provide Staffing
and provide HR services to folks who are
looking to contract or work and develop
in other countries anybody can anybody
can participate but we're basically
focused on open source aligned open
source creators open source
consultancies
um and it's uh these two organizations
opening Global ESPN Not Venture funded
not looking for Venture funding these
are bootstrapping working for
potentially private Equity or other
investors who don't mind uh we're not
looking to scale these big and hope you
know go go big or go home because we're
never gonna go home openings Global and
ospn are going to be here uh 10 years
from now and we're going to basically
keep working to support people's
employment efforts across the world we
have a great HR team Act we can only do
this because the great team that we've
been able to pull together these people
are available to help recruit find
employ work across the world
open teams I said open teams its purpose
is to again create this community of
Open Source Architects tech leads
advisors enthusiasts it doesn't matter
where you are doesn't matter if you want
a freelance job or not you can join this
network and actually work with
like-minded folks you do have to apply
to the network
open source Professional Network
ospn.org open to everybody just no
matter you know early young doesn't
matter the Osa Community requires some
experience
um right now uh it's me and two other
people that are administering who joins
uh other people are welcome to join as
we get more people in it we'll have
we'll broaden the the application
process but right now
um this this group is intended to help
make open source better for business I
was just at a dinner with a friend who
works at a large bank and he was telling
about his development team and the work
they do
they have about
um there's a there's there's roughly
they could cut their development staff
by at least half is my strong belief
that if they would actually use open
source more effectively if they would
actually use the people that are in open
source communities driving and there's
things you have to do specifically it's
not just you know download Open Source
software it's actually engage with the
communities and have some have the right
kind of Contracting processes they could
easily save half their budgets and so
there's a lot of money there available
if we can organize correctly and engage
with people correctly so that's the
purpose of open teams currently our go
to market is basically open source
support and you can go and we're
learning we're growing we're still a
startup and this company is one that we
believe could be scaled and grown with
Venture money so but um we're working on
that right now the you know everyone
here you know look at it see if you want
to apply there are many many people here
that we absolutely welcome in the Osa
community so if you are interested in
learning we basically will have
um kind of one event a week essentially
micro events you know Zoom calls
conferences we'll have a a co-located
boss in multiple conferences it's a way
to kind of come together and exchange
ideas and learn from each other you do
again you do have to apply if you're
interested seven years of experience uh
one or two years of leadership
experience on a tech project that's kind
of what we're looking for it's just
started uh then you can come share in
your area of accuracies and other areas
of expertise this is open to not just
python by the way this is all open
source and so we'll have four forums and
groups and various things like that that
will organize within it but that's what
we're doing at openteams.com actually is
that and then we help people actually
affect those those change processes in
an organization to create the world now
quantite for example is a partner of
open teams it's what we call it open
source architect partner and so if uh
and so there's a lot of Cooperative
sales energy between the two one of the
ideas one of the things that open teams
for example is growing is something
where I'm I'm calling repos it's a
little bit play on words it's reimbursed
enhancement proposals for open source
this is an idea we've been basically
incubating for a long time it's actually
behind what's funded data apis for us
data API is is this go to data apis.org
it's the second attempt to unify arrays
numpy was the first and now of course
you know 10 years later there's many
many more arrays than the two that I
started with to try to unify
not going to be able to unify them all
but not only a lot of arrays are a lot
of data frames too and so data apis is a
community effort it's a group of folks
Labs is a is a main contributor then
many many people in the community
basically who are and the funding for it
has come from these ideas that we have
for how to get companies to pay for open
source but the key thing about repos is
it's got to be led by community
maintainers
the community Architects have to be the
ones driving it forward it's it's it's
not us it's not open teams it's
basically hey the community says we want
to move the move this this community
this direction here's the feature set
here's the list of things and open teams
will help well great let's go find
funding we use ourselves and marketing
efforts to go fight funding we've
already identified three specific ways
we can get funding and we're looking and
we can we'll keep exploring until we
find them anymore and then you get
collaborative funding because a lot of
times you know currently you try to get
funding it's like okay get that one
company to spend all the money on doing
it but okay it's 250 000 one company may
not be able to give you 250 000 then
maybe you can get 10 companies to give
you twenty five thousand dollars but
then how do you organize that and
coordinate it so that's that's what we
mean by repos it's a it's a way to
organize our sales and resources to make
this happen
all right finally
um last few minutes I want to talk about
what quantite's doing to enable this
Innovation Innovation requires iteration
all you want to innovate there's much
more Innovation to go out there as we
described to do it you got to iterate
quickly like it's not magic actually you
basically can take somebody's curiosity
passion couple it with tools let them
iterate quickly and what do you know
things start to emerge if they cooperate
with others there's usually compliance
and organizations that are required so
it constrains this in some fashion these
constraints usually what creates all the
technical debt that most companies are
weighed under there's ways around that
though
nabari many of you've heard of nabari
nabari is basically a Jupiter Hub
distribution it's a it's a devops tool
that enables people to quickly put
something together and start exploring
we actually for most of our
organizations most of the people we go
to consult with we call it a reference
architecture because it's basically an
example of how you can do this you could
use it and keep using it that's fine or
you can just learn from it and say oh we
could do this in our organization and so
it enables ml Ops data science mlops
basically with Integrations to other
libraries dast
um notebooks as a service is coming Argo
uh clear ML and others
um the challenge with iteration is that
data all of our activity makes this
stuff go so fast we iterate so quickly
we create these very complex
environments so it's super easy to
basically build it once and have it work
on your machine
right and then go and then now what
right cool now the IT department says I
gotta have all these constraints I have
all these compliance requirements now
what do I do
I can't anticipate the libraries you
want some people try to lock it down and
there's this basic distension we all are
all aware of
I'm going to talk about that containers
are part of the solution but not the
entire Solution please please please
stop using vendored Wheels
I mean that's essentially in one
sentence my problem with current
packaging is vendored Wheels they're not
needed you don't need to do them it's
just so stop doing it I know why I know
it's tempting I know you're hearing
about it I know that seems like the
right way to go and as though it's
available but it doesn't help you it
gets you something once but then you
it's it's technical debt effectively and
we constantly require encountering
people have this technical debt they
have to unravel that's one way to sum up
the great work that Ralph has done in
describing the pi packaging discussion
there are best practices conda is one
package manager there are others you
know there are other ways not to use
vendor Wheels than to use conda there
are other ways so I'm not just Shilling
for condo I like conda but there are
other ways but just use a complete
package manager use something that lets
you do this for real
and there's ways to do this better we've
taken these best practices and created
something called condo store
kind of store makes it basically focus
on the environment instead of the
packages so create the environment and
then easily lets the teams of people use
environments easily so it controls the
environment life cycle and forces best
practices manages version Access Control
kind of environments so there's UI and
basically it enforces reproducibility
environment specification so it starts
with environment specifications so do
that instead of content installed
packages just change your environment
then you create a lock file update your
lock file
and then you can create build artifacts
from that either in fully environments
or Docker containers or just binary tar
install
all right I want to talk more about that
and I think I'm out of time so I have
some advice here but I think I'm going
to go quickly to one slide which is
basically code with a community care
about people more than code and they'll
go a lot lot farther so thank you
everybody I appreciate being here and
I'm here's to another 30 Years thank you
thank you thank you for this amazing
talk it was really inspiring to know
about your contributions and your
promotions towards making the python
libraries and making it open source to
accessible by all all the people thank
you thank you once again
absolutely
maybe it's time for questions
hi Travis
oh sorry it is on I just have to eat it
more thank you for the talk I'm hearing
a consistent theme this is my first Pi
data conference I'm hearing this
consistent theme of it's really hard to
fund all these projects which you know
has been the question I've had since I
discovered open source back in 1999.
my question is does the federal
government fund any of this and if not
why not because they fund all of
research and this is basic research yeah
great question
um so I would say yes now more than 10
years ago and there's some great people
in Academia at Nasa at the federal
funded organizations that are doing a
great job I think it could be vastly
improved still I think there's still
some it's basically because the heroic
efforts of a few key people that they're
doing it at all some of this is just uh
social change takes a long time you know
basically it moves the pace of human
life spans and human careers if you love
a mental model and then it takes a while
it's changing because that mental model
is changing people are recognizing
exactly your point right
um in fact my view is if the federal
government is funding software it should
why isn't it open source rather than you
make an excuse for it to be open source
it's like that should be the the rule
not the exception
um but part of it comes from that
question of okay people are saying well
just Produce open source produced open
source how does it get sustained and so
that's a reasonable question but again
there are some reasonable answers
actually and I think it just takes some
uh creativity collaboration conversation
there's not just Federal money there's
billions of dollars of federal money
that's out there that could obviously be
used to sustain and some of it is now
the NASA Grant the Roses Grant there's
the European agency there's there's
there there's more but it's a trickle
compared to what's possible
um but there's at least 900 trillion
dollars of investment Capital out there
looking for investment meanwhile open
source is the foundation of mostly
Innovations of the past 10 years
that's a big disconnect right that needs
to flow better it is Flowing to some
degree Venture funds are flowing it
they're you know companies are flowing
it but I would say it's very inefficient
still but government absolutely can do a
better job I'm not the person to talk I
collaborate with the academic world to
do that but I think it's a good question
anyone else
okay thank you then
absolutely thank you